hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast accelerating cancer research
and clinical innovations using uncle and
it is presented by being Joe PhD a
senior scientist in bioinformatics at
cryogen I am Judy O'Rourke of laberd's
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by kyochon for more
information about our sponsor visit wwii
gen calm before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box it appears on the screen
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Joe I will now turn the presentation
over to her
so this is being from comics a division
of Chi genes by informatics today I'm
excited to talk about uncle rants a very
popular cancer genomics repository and
visualization platform and how it can
contribute to your fast-paced cancer
research and clinical innovation
first I would like to give a brief
introduction of the land context and its
data source then I would like to walk
you through three study cases some of
the analytic tubes and uncle Len to show
you how to address common scientific
questions such as how to define
nutritional express genes and find their
association clinical Association how to
utilize valuable meta data from TCGA
pan-cancer studies to help you explore
clinical survival endpoints and fund
biologically relevant subgroups and how
uncle land can facilitate target
discovery and clinical innovations uses
the RI CRISPR datasets hopefully by the
end of the talk you get to know uncle
reg and how uncle and can accelerate
your cancer research and climate
information
as you see all commands we can view
uncle and in a number of different ways
uncle man can be viewed as a large
matrix where on the y-axis is the sample
level data
which includes sample level metadata as
well as patient clinical data it also
includes sample group PL clustering
information and simple level measurement
data on the x-axis it's the gene level
data including the adaptation of the
chest groups and different genome build
and the value of each cell is actual
genomic data
which includes here mutations copy
number aberrations expression of a gene
or protein and the methylation data
another way to look at the data is based
on the data types on Quran contain
multiple data types for example at the
DNA level we have CNS week's somatic
mutations we have copy number variations
at the RNA level we have sequencing data
based on micro RNA or mRNA we also have
expression data based on array Express
at the person level we have MS
rppa rppa rbn as well as to Schumaker a
data and at the epigenetic level we have
methylation data
histogram shows a summary of uncle rants
based on the number of samples and data
type as you can see our land collection
can be grouped into four major
categories
the first one is the body mask
collection which includes samples from
normal cell lines and tissues it
includes the well-known teeth the gtex
data sets and the HBA it is it
the second category is the cancer cell
line collection which includes data from
different cancer cell lines and the
third category is a tissue yet between
tumor in the general collection in this
collection there is a tremendous amount
of samples from both normal and cancers
and this category includes most popular
data consumption data for example the
TCGA ICGC datasets as well as datasets
from public repository
the last category of data is so-called
tumor specific collections which focus
on specific types of cancers such as
childhood cancers in Pediatrics land and
target lands and blogger related cancers
include appointed land to summarize the
land based on data types you will see
that TCGA men DCL event prevalence have
more integrative data types
more detailed summary of different data
types in uncle and uncle man's release
estate new data and new features on the
quarterly basis
I highlighted some of the recent updates
from our 2018 quarter three for example
we added new detect call to LA based on
the immunohistochemistry staining for HP
ale and we also added around 5,000 new
compressor based on Tennessee commute
ation setters of commonly mutated
oncogenic genes such as those found in
the classic targeted DNA panels and
comparisons based on key clinical
variables such as HP a better
we added a brand new Lance called math
500 and the samples in lick this land
are so Lila static tumors from different
cancer types
can see Aqualand cards may contain more
than 200,000 samples many dear friends
diseases and tissue categories
and feature a tremendous amount of data
and the data source can be grouped into
streaming categories with the majority
of the data derived from construction
projects such as the well-known TCGA
gtex ICGC and target dataset this
diagram summarizes the major
construction data that are managed by
two large data warehouses eg a and DB
gap the second category of data comes
from thousands of individual studies
that are deposited under public demands
such as geo or Express and SRA
to be noted that aqua menstruation team
has spent a lot of time to attract the
project and sample level information
with using Onix soft internal controlled
vocabulary to make all these data sets
that are consistent and comparable
across different data sources the third
character of data come from our
available customer requests which I will
highlight today one of the most popular
requests for uncle G lands is to edit
the immunotherapy study
cancer immunotherapy uses of our immune
system to fight cancer the work to help
the immune systems recognize in attacks
cancer cells it is now a standard
treatment for some type of cancer and it
is still in development and clinical
trials for other types the term
immunotherapy can compress a wide
variety of concepts and measures which
including monoclonal antibodies
checkpoint inhibitors feta kite vaccines
and adoptive cell therapy
some of the most promising recent
developments in this field include use
of personalized tumor specific vaccines
as well as the drive towards immune
checkpoint activation for molecules such
as PD 1 and 11 PDL one so far uncle
Julian have already landed more than 100
immunotherapy studies which are highly
highlighted some of the data curry
keywords in red
here is an example of one of those
immunotherapy studies and uncle Gio led
uncle Gio is a collection of individual
apology related releases from public
repository this collection also includes
onyx oft curated compression data from
this project such as disease versus
normal treatment versus control in this
example the study published in the
journal Cell is 2017 the cool part of
patients with no static melanoma was
treated with PD one checkpoint baracus
therapy based on a compression of
responses versus non-responsive
schirmer's we can easily detect a group
of genes that are officially up
regulated in responsive tumors as shown
on the left
in uncle ranch users can easily browse
results from this comparison users can
also group samples based on metadata or
clinical data and explore survival
analysis
right it kept in their analysis of
patient's overall survival as you can
see mzp-1 responsive patients have
significantly better survival compared
to non-responsive patients
uncle lines also allow users to build
customer lands with internal and
external data enabling combined analysis
and rapid data extension an example of
the customer lands join here is the data
hosted under DB gap so-called Stand Up
to Cancer control data
in supplement to the TCGA expression
data that focused on the primary tumors
the customers had a core application
with us to assess your chest grim term
sequencing data from the static
castration resistant prostate cancer in
this collaboration we helped processing
the RNA seek data and curate the
metadata we helped integrate the
different data types as well as you can
see this land health around 50 samples
with 43 of these samples have both whole
transcriptome sequencing data as well as
seeing the somatic mutation data on the
right showing you an example of the
integrated view of gene expression and
copy number of peteandjayne
in this land as you all know
inactivation of P 10 by deletion or
mutations has been constantly and
unified in the run twenty percent of
primary posse tumors and in Wars and
fifty percent of castration resistant
tumors the loss of kitchen functions
leads to activation of pi3 kinase Akt
pathway which has been shown to be
associated with adverse oncogenic
outcomes
you
so with the previous introduction I
believe I already shown you that uncle
land has tremendous amount of data in
there but Uncle land is more than just a
comprehensive repository of almac data
it also feature advanced analytic tools
and modules and allow integrative
analysis and customer multiple music
visualization here I'll use some study
cases to show you how uncle and can
accelerate your cancer research
in the first example is a study done a
clear cell renal cell carcinoma
as we know genetic changes underlies
clear cell renal cell carcinoma include
alterations in genes controlling seller
oxygen senses such as the gel and the
maintenance of conscience stages such as
PDR and one in this study that published
on the Journal of nature the author's
demonstrated in model a shift in the
processing of the grcc tumor progression
that aggressive cancers demonstrated
down regulation of genes involved in TCA
cycle and up regulation of the pentose
phosphate pathway genes such as P G LS
using this dedicate I would like to
illustrate how easily to anti defy
differentially expressed genes and its
correlated genes and how to perform
survival analysis and broadly examining
clinical data to find meaningful
clinical associations
as I mentioned uncle and precomputed
carefully curated comparison funding
from literature's : compression tabs and
uncle Gio land for instance includes
tumor versus normal drug treatment
versus control treatment
differences between different cell types
and tissues as well as different disease
subgroups with statistical analysis to
identify differentially expressed genes
within this group
here looking at a disease versus normal
compression and then interactive okay no
props for TCGA PIRC project
these tech analysis of differentially
expressed genes with change displayed on
the x-axis and T values on the y-axis
within a rate you do users can customize
the visualization of each view for
example you can customize the cutoff
line
the dots represent a gene what are you
going to display as a gene ID or
annotation of the genes you can
customize the size of the notes by
showing conscious corresponding to
adjusted p-values
from this land can easily be exported in
table format as well and you can upload
this data to IPA for further analysis
one statistic in verses reports of
differentially expressed genes have been
generated users can create the create a
gene set from the selection of
interested genes into further analysis
the analysis including the gene set
enrichment analysis
which can be viewed in both club format
or table format here within the platform
at I selected two data sets
there is a number of views available for
users to browse multiple comparisons to
see whether there is overlapping gene
regulations for example there is volcano
clause for each of the good persons or
you can use the violent diagrams view to
see which genes overlap in this
comparison selecting any points within
the diagram will allow users to identify
genes commonly differentially expressed
in this comparison
besides searching a gene
users can also search comparisons based
on specific genes for example you can
search the P GLS gene and group the
samples based on tumor versus normal
comparisons in krz projects
and here we confirmed that P GLS is
upregulated in tumors and normal samples
after you search a gene based on
user-defined grouping users can easily
for correlative genes by integration
analysis and this analysis can apply to
multiple data types for example
correlation can be analysis - based on
RNA seek expressions
duplex data or say envy and RNA seek
expression data or somatic mutation and
artistic expression data
as shown here
I'm searching a gene called P GLS the
resulting output was divided into two
windows the scatterplot with a value of
courage genes on x axis and the
correlated genes on a y axis and a
correlation table on the Left showing
the pot top correlated gene sorted by
value of correlation we can use the
correlation table to further filter this
results States on correlation score or
genes within certain pathways
here by applying the filter to find
correlations of more than point five and
find genes within the phosphate a
pentose phosphate pathway we can define
a list of genes that are correlated with
expression of T GLS
further explore this jeans by customer
curry of available data to see whether
these jeans had any clinical endpoint
associations here I'm using tk2 Jean as
an example
this gene encodes a chess skeleton the
chance catalyst
Aqualand customer queries allow users to
identify samples that match user defined
criteria this then were added as
metadata columns these metadata can be
used for subsequent filtering or sorting
or gookie
users can add custom McCurry's based on
gene expression mutation setters copy
number status or fusion status
here I'm trying to recoup the key I rc+
samples based on RNA seek fpkm of PG LSD
this grouping was then added enter
customer curry and users can plug gene
expressions they samba school team
users can also easily find associated
survival analysis based on the school
team as shown here we find high
expressions of P GLS and TNT that are
associated with decreased overall
survival in K IRC projects
most of the construction data also come
with extensive clinical metadata uncle
lands provide powerful functions to
explore and visualize these clinical
variables and explore how they correlate
with other data by group associations
analysis
in this example samples are grouped by
custom occur rate of PG LS artistic
expression as we elect rated in pervious
life we find that that PG LS gene
expression are significantly associated
with tumor a GCC pathological stage and
his logical great in the TCGA PRF II
cohorts
result is also customizable users can
filter the results based on that is too
cluttered or p-values or they can
further verify their funding by looking
at the T GLS gene expression view
here I stratify the samples by hdçç
press illogical tumor stage and cancer
grades and view the gene expression of
PG OS as predicted an operation of P GLS
jeans with the progression of clear cell
renal cell carcinoma as you can see we
can regenerate several of the key
findings in the nature paper by simply
apply some of the built-in analytic to
and on colons
second staticy I would like to introduce
the valuable information we get from the
TCGA pan-cancer study with in TCGA Lance
the motivation behind this is to enrich
the TCGA metadata that are not available
in GE e to add diverse clustering
results from their multi-armed
acknowledges and choose further
as the further period clinical metadata
we believe the clustering with
information can help our users to define
biological relevance sample subgroups
and help sample stratification using
original to TCG and metadata
cancer clinical data will enable
high-quality survival analysis as well
which can further
improve our target discovery
so the tcga market
my data is located under the clinical
data in TCGA land so far based on the
cluster and platform we have grouped
into 15 different categories
we have included the TCGA Network
publications including 28 papers from
focusing on specific cancer types and
nine written to publish the pan-cancer
studies which I'll be focusing on today
GTG network investigators had
characterized the molecular landscape of
tumors from over 11,000 patients across
serving three cancer types they
reclassified the tumors - based on
multiple omics data and reviewed common
rows of cancer as you all know insights
about how one type of cancer related to
another can have real clinical
implications in some cases we can borrow
clinical practices from well known
disease and apply them to cancers for
which treatment options are less well
defined
showing below is a regeneration of what
dr. Hoadley had discovered in herself
paper using TCGA land the tumors of
Screenland pathology showing the grain
bar it doesn't matter if the tumors are
from long or head and neck or cervix to
MERS they show similar gene expression
micro RNA as well as protein cluttering
the pen cancer early studies provide an
additional resource for the development
of new treatments in pursuit of
precision medicine
the new liter is to feature a pan-cancer
clone of the data erase the clinical
endpoints by including the disease
specific level progression free interval
as well as disease-free interval
besides overall survival as you all know
overall survival is considered the most
reliable cancer endpoint in gold
standard for cancer clinical research
these basic survival exclude events a
cause of death rather than discuss the
fake disease
both endpoints may require longer study
or larger study cohort in order to
prevent a efficiency
which is not suitable for tumors with
good prognosis in this case the
disease-free interval and the
progression for interval may be
considers they found the study goal
different types of survival endpoints
were chosen
and our TCGA lens provides options to
choose the specific survival and plan
for your survival endpoint analyses
besides survival I'll come enough is
newly added metadata from can suspend
cancer marker papers have other
implications for example users can
search any numerical clinical variables
from the current TCG metadata
the marbles the variables including
mutation rate or a new cell compartment
in this example and searching T cells
cd8 positive compartment samples can be
stratified based on pan-cancer
eye clusters
or other clusterer information we would
like to explore which subgroup of
samples define that I cluster that have
higher infiltration of federal taxes
that are toxic T cells
customers can also easily customize in
the symbols by metadata clinical data
for a customer Chloe
for example showing here the samples are
colored by expression level of CCL pride
expression the cl5 has been shown to be
differentially expressed in terms with
high and low cd8 positive T cell
infiltration we subject for whether CCL
five expressions have any association
with survival endpoints
here I'm using a c10 cluster as an
example
as you can see based on I cluster high
expression of CCL 5 is associated with
better disease specific survival in
Seton I cluster
oops which contains a large group of
head and neck streamers patients however
when we stretch by the sample space on
tumor types we cannot see this direct
association between CCL 5 expression and
disease let's take the Bible
a pan-cancer clustering master data
provides additional ways to stratify
samples based on onic data similarity
which may help and g25 biological
relevance sample subgroups and
suggestions future directions for
targeted therapy
last example I would like to talk about
our exciting ongoing integration of the
rni CRISPR data into the CTL event and
how this meant massive silicate the
target discovery and therapeutic drug
screening
our current ctrl and already contain
multiple data types including invade
mutation in expression and occupied
protein data the additional new data for
the cell line sensitivity to different
molecular cultivations
including compound training as well as
iron like CRISPR screening the objective
of this integration is to devise better
understanding for cancer vulnerabilities
and to help refine potential molecular
target genes
in this development we added the CTR P
drop measurement data where more than
800 cancer cell lines were exposed to
more than 500 compounds with well-known
mechanism of action
we also in the process of integrating
the accolades and drive datasets to
determine essential genes for cancer
cell survival we're looking at here an
example from the mango HPG as you can
see here we're showing the gene
dependency score of angle HB genes
across all 50 Lu cell lines on X's sss
is the cell line
have the lowest dependency score means
their survival are more dependent on
L'Engle HP jeez
to get a sense of how the integrated
data going to look like
I'm using an example from a publication
in this recent publication Metro
experience and Lango extremes was shown
to be provoking and similar to
simultaneous loss of the Stooges
decrease viability by looking at the
into practice view of copy number
variation of mango extremes and Jun
dependency score of language speaking
you can easily discover that mango
experience is the top gene dependency in
cells that have hemizygous mango each
dilution projecting a rationale for
targeting Mangal HP access in cancers
we all know functional redundancy shared
by colleges may applause protection
against the genetic perturbations but is
also resolved in genetic amount ability
due to mutual interdependence II this
RNA CRISPR data combined with existing
ctle data provide a valuable source to
provide valuable insights on therapeutic
development
in summary we can see that uncle land
holds tremendous amount of consultant
data and tens of thousands of process
and carefully curated cancer genomics
datasets from public domains
the high level is HD metadata making
meaningful connections between our Amish
data and sample and subject level data
can also build customer lands with
internal and external data which allow
users to combine data from different
sources and enable uncle-aunty
to rapid data expansion
uncle and also provide advanced analytic
tools allowing users to navigate data
across multiple platforms and get
meaningful biological and clinical
insights in minutes
you
some of the ongoing efforts and future
developments for Uncle land including
the following first we would like to
stay current with related state native
the data
we would synchronize with the new
construction data release we also are
integrating some of the land in the
thirty-eighth version we would continue
as more interesting new data sets into
land for example we would like to add
targeted therapy projects we would also
like to add some of the Mouse projects
and our customer request is always our
higher priority where continue our
developments to integrate the iron.i
crystal data into the CC allele and as
well
okay considering time I will not be able
to show all the features of on :
we do have a lot of cool features such
as we have built-in genome browsers we
have also included the all make print
overview of all genomic operations that
I have included here if you want your
interested to get access to teach you
the introduction over our land contents
or additional training resources I
highly recommend you to take a look at
our all Microsoft uncle land wiki pages
comics oft have provided very intensive
and advanced tutorials and study cases
to help you effectively use the
resources and further your research and
a clinical discovery with more quickly
and more successfully
finally I'd like to thank you for your
time and attention and at this point I
would like to take any questions Thank
You dr. Joe for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email so let's get started
our first question is how do you locate
immunotherapy projects in uncle geo land
currently an uncle Gio land as shown
here most of the immunotherapy studies
can be found entered the therapeutic
area of project level if you check the
immunomodulator button you can find the
teacher level immunotherapy studies and
there's three main categories for
example you can find them enter the
columns of treatments subject treatments
as well as transaction
thank you how does uncle Len
standardized the metadata related to the
multi-omics data across different
projects
I think the duration of al-quran matter
data really stands out uncle and with
other data constructions it's because
uncle land has included very intensive
metadata curations
example for our consumption data we have
tried to preserve original data content
we add control color and we do Senators
checking and consistency checking we
will let some Crossland columns that
will enable Crossland comparisons
for the public data source where we
included thousands of individual studies
from public domain we use our internal
curation to to do curation we try to
completely extract the project level and
sample level information we do
annotations using our controlled
vocabularies and we standardize the data
using our predefined format
our tuitions was done by multiple
iterations per project to ensure the
consistency of the duration
thank you okay we have time for one more
question if I found data sets of
interests that are not in current uncle
uncle land is it possible to add those
in land to enable combined analysis
that's a very good question actually we
value our customer requests very much
and customer can send any public
available data set if you find it not
existing on coolant you can send this to
our customer support we can add them for
you
and if you find a businesses that are
controlled at South data you can also
contact us we would like to sell a cool
application with you and we can build
custom along for you as well well thank
you I would like to once again thank dr.
Jo for her presentation I would also
like to thank cryogen for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through February 15th
2019 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye